tout le monde se souvient de ces images
tout le monde se rappelle de ce mois de
juillet 2018 la France est sacrée
championne du monde cette année les
Bleus remettent leur titre en jeu
pourtant il ne semble pas y avoir un
grand engouement autour de ce Mondial au
Qatar alors pourquoi cette année tout le
monde s'en fiche réponse dans factures
[Applaudissements]
en 2022 46% des Français ont l'intention
de suivre la Coupe du Monde selon un
sondage réalisé par odoxab pour Winamax
et RTL c'est un taux très en deçà de ce
qu'on mesure pour une coupe du monde on
était à 66% pour la Coupe du Monde 2018
mais même pour un euro on est sur des
niveaux supérieurs 51 % d'intention de
suivre l'euro 2021 avant la compétition
56% pour l'Euro 2016 qui se déroulait en
France alors comment expliquer ce net
recul d'abord c'est une question de
calendrier c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire qu'une coupe du monde se joue
à cette période au mois de novembre avec
une finale prévue le 18 décembre
d'habitude les Bleus se regroupent un
mois avant le début de la compétition il
y a une montée en pression médiatique
autour de ce rassemblement les
supporters voient passer sur les réseaux
sociaux dans la presse des extraits
d'entraînement et d'interview
cette année il n'y a rien et il n'aura
rien seulement 7 jours sépare le dernier
match du championnat et le début de la
Coupe du monde les médias n'en parle pas
avant chaque jeu avant chaque grand
événement il y a des tiseurs il y a
plein plein de choses qui disent à plus
qu'un mois plus de mois plus de 3 mois
et on voit ça partout je m'en souviens
pour Tokyo je m'en souviens pour un
beaging pour pour Rio il y avait à
chaque fois chaque fois chaque fois et
bien une une annonce de l'événement on
mettait l'eau à la bouche en disant bah
voilà bientôt bientôt si seulement même
chose pour les pubs en été les pubs pour
les boissons rafraîchissantes par
exemple sont diffusés bien avant de la
compétition mais là en plein hiver qui
en aura réellement envie selon l'Ifop
52% des Français cuisineront ou
consommeront du fait maison pour
regarder la Coupe du monde cette année
une baisse de 5 points par rapport à une
période traditionnelle et si on ajoute à
ça les Bleus qui ne font pas rêver c'est
que la question de la cohésion au sein
du groupe France et le point sur lequel
les Français sont les moins confiants à
l'approche de la Coupe du Monde et puis
1958 les Bleus n'ont jamais enchaîné
autant de défaites avant une coupe du
monde entre les différentes polémiques
les blessures de certains joueurs
l'ambiance elle a fédération l'équipe de
France traverse une mauvaise passe la
cohésion parce qu'il y a des risques de
peut-être de bizzbee-t-il entre Paul
Pogba et Kylie Mbappe entre différents
joueurs pour des raisons de sélection
non sélection et du coup il y a aussi
Karim Benzema et Olivier Giroud donc là
où l'inquiétude est la plus forte pour
l'équipe de France n'est pas sur le
niveau de jeu des joueurs ni sur la
maîtrise du groupe par Didier Deschamps
mais bien sur les relations entre les
joueurs et ça pose la question de la
cohésion certains restent quand même
positifs moi je me rappelle en 2002 la
gestion de la pression on n'a pas réussi
à l'avoir on était dans une spirale qui
nous a emmené négative des joueurs
blessés Zidane tirer Henry Robert Pirès
et donc il faut absolument la casser si
la pression est gérée et la spirale et à
ce moment là je crois que l'équipe de
France fait partie des équipes favorites
c'est évident enfin le fait que ce soit
le Qatar qui organise cette compétition
refroidit un certain nombre de
supporters 68% des Français attendent
que les représentants officiels du
football en France mais aussi Emmanuel
Macron manifeste publiquement leur
critique c'est une attente forte des
Français parce que finalement ils
souhaitent que ce soit prise en main
cette dimension politique de l'événement
pour rester sur un événement sportif il
n'attendent pas par exemple que les
joueurs de l'équipe de France refusent
de jouer la Coupe du Monde par contre
ils attendent un geste symbolique de la
part des joueurs de l'équipe de France
pour montrer leur des approbations Paris
Marseille Lyon Reims et tout un tas
d'autres villes en France l'ont déjà
annoncé elle ne diffuseront pas les
matchs sur des écrans géants une
décision qui risque d'impacter l'intérêt
des supporters la ville comme je l'ai
dit déjà clairement hier ne va pas
mettre en place de zone de diffusion
d'abord parce que les conditions
environnementales notamment et sociales
nous questionnent sur l'événement et ce
n'est pas le modèle que l'on souhaite
promouvoir de grands événements à Paris
ça c'est la première raison et la
deuxième raison elle est que cette Coupe
du Monde a lieu en décembre comme ça on
a échappé à personne et que de faire une
zone de célébration en réunissant
beaucoup de monde sur cette période-là
me semble pas non plus le mieux
approprié donc cette Coupe du Monde
va-t-elle être suivie
en plus de ça dans un dans un morosité
totale c'est un match je sais pas toi on
sait qu'aujourd'hui le sport marche dans
une logique
de vouloir échapper